tiempo para ahondar en la información
económica en france 24 para ello
contamos con nuestro compañero
especializado jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido y hoy vamos a hacer una
programación especial con motivo de las
próximas elecciones en costa rica vamos
a ahondar en este espacio en los retos
que tendrá quien sea el próximo
presidente del país y es que aunque este
país puede considerarse de ingresos
medio alto y es una historia o es
conocido como una historia de éxito en
desarrollo económico al menos durante
los últimos 25 años también tiene
grandes desafíos como la desigualdad el
acceso al mercado laboral y una elevada
deuda pública es economía también vive
una elevada inflación como consecuencia
del impacto de la pandemia y problemas
externos en febrero el dato interanual
fue del 4,90 por ciento el más alto en
10 años y pese a que el crecimiento
económico de costa rica fue del 76 por
ciento en 2021 y los buenos datos de
exportaciones el déficit primario más
bajo en 13 años rodrigo chávez josé
maría figueres los dos principales
candidatos para dirigir el país deben
afrontar una elevada deuda pública que
es equivalente al 70 por ciento del
producto
de ese país sobre este tema consultamos
antes con el economista costarricense
juan carlos cerdas escuchamos el déficit
fiscal es el principal reto que enfrenta
a costa rica para los próximos años el
este domingo de hecho tenemos elecciones
presidenciales y ninguno de los
candidatos me parece que ha tratado el
tema de la emergencia fiscal por así
decirlo con la seriedad o las medidas
contundentes para enfrentar lo que se
necesitan
costa rica de cada colon de ingreso que
obtiene el gobierno medio colon
va dedicado al pago de intereses lo cual
es altamente grave para la productividad
la inversión porque pues sabemos que
esos recursos se podrían dedicar a
infraestructura a escuelas a programas
sociales
y es algo que sea de cierto punto de
vista normalizado ya que el gobierno
funcione con un mismo nivel de
endeudamiento
por así decirlo el déficit primario que
son los gastos e intereses del gobierno
está casi tablas en el 0 por ciento del
pib mientras que el déficit financiero
que ya incluye el pago de intereses de
deuda 25 por ciento del pib entonces
imagínate el nivel de recursos y costa
rica está desperdiciando por no tratar
esta crisis con seguridad y entonces lo
que pasa es que a pesar de que todos
estos préstamos de cualquier organismo
internacional sea fondo monetario o sea
banco mundial vengan a muy buenos plazos
a muy buenas tasas de interés
es básicamente si lo traducimos a
finanzas personales usar una tarjeta de
crédito para pagar otra tarjeta de
crédito
rodrigo el fondo monetario internacional
recomendó a costa rica mejoras en el
sistema tributario para que sea más
equitativo también sugirió que respalde
una disminución equilibrada del déficit
fiscal y asegure sostenibilidad en la
deuda pública a medio plazo pero jorge
en el contexto actual también costa rica
tiene problemas de desigualdad y falta
de empleo allí por ejemplo el empleo
informal ronda o superior inclusive al
40% una reciente encuesta elaborada por
el instituto nacional de estadísticas y
censos da cuenta de casi un millón de
personas en la informalidad
allí la pobreza afecta el 23 por ciento
de la población y los desempleados
representan el 14 por ciento en costa
rica buena parte de la población no se
siente parte de este crecimiento
económico del país y esto ya ha generado
grandes descontentos con la política
sobre esto nos habló nuestro invitado
si costa rica tiene una pobreza que hace
más de 20 años está estancada en un 20%
la desigualdad a pesar de que el país
tiene un sistema educativo muy fuerte y
accesible con una universalización del
acceso a la educación pública se explica
mucho tanto por el ingreso a las
universidades
que es limitado me parece que menos del
20 por ciento de los gravados
de colegio de educación secundaria
logran egresar una universidad
versus una creación de empleo que es
calificado entonces los principales
generales de empleo en costa rica son
las que se le conoce como los regímenes
especiales o la régimen de zona franca
que son hembras de todo el mundo que
establecen sus plantas de manufactura y
producción a cambio de no pagar
impuestos sobre la renta de sus
operaciones pero esa empresa lo que
necesitan son ingenieros científicos
pero serán calificados que
lastimosamente sobre todo si hablamos de
la zona rural no se encuentra disponible
bueno jorge muchos retos por delante
desde luego para el próximo presidente y
recordemos que aquí en 324 estaremos muy
atentos a todo lo que pasa en estas
elecciones gracias por estar con
nosotros ya nuestros espectadores les
recordamos que pueden seguir conectados
a france 24 en france 24 punto com
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]